[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment ils les six autres les biens -
les mieux alors est ce que j'allais bien
que les deux autres fauteuils pas fait
on commence on est dans les hauts de
saint joseph
on est chez carole et nicolas et sur le
terrain d'un tas d'affaires n'atteint
d'affaires dont palmiste rouge palmiste
rouge ses maîtres dans le car il mange
en salades toutes les mamans y plaisons
personne donc ne propose deux suivants
main tout de suite et vient vite vite
vite vite on y va bonjour carole
blanchard comme mon idée mais elle est
là même déjà mais aussi devenu un
plaisir alors isolement où ça nous les
et que ça vous fait alors là nous de la
crête deuxième village attention des
mamans et mamies
mêlée dans l'agriculture biologique ne
plante palmiste rouge d'ananas gingembre
agrumes et attaque et pas jusqu'où je me
marre et pico chez nana palmiste rouge
et gris quoi notamment tout ça s'il te
plaît alors il va nous montrer tout ça
parce que bon c'est trop joli ça et
c'est beau en plus tard par ici
[Musique]
alors nicolas ne descende un petit peu
sur l'exploitation plus par en bas parce
que la littérature la marmaille un là
qu'on commence depuis dans les là-bas
haute saône ou à lactalis n'a tout comme
à dire du mal du coup pour ça qu'il
connaît pas cui fait grimper palm hills
nous nous connaît 1
mais bonne nadon face à peut-être je
connais pas et cela certainement
regarder mais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
de palmiste mais bon je dis bonjour oui
manger en famille le coeur palmisano dit
chantal miss météores et bob iger dycker
pamiers pour cathy comprends mais c'est
pas grave
pourquoi le père miss rouge dans le sud
sauvage est ce que c'est
c'est vraiment une variété palmistes qui
qui acceptent mieux le climat est ce que
c'est ou alors c'est vraiment une
question de goût du de polochons voit
mal le palmiste problème de l'eau déjà
donc il faut nous les là dans le sud
sud-est en plus nous pourrait dire parce
que c'est là puis donne paquet comme il
faut ensuite lui pousse bien dans les
bars et saint-philippe n'a beaucoup de
planteurs palmiste rouge mais lui ça va
aussi dans les eaux jusqu'à 600 700 800
mètres d'altitude aussi d'accord
notamment un petit pull et les plus les
plombs juvénile de palmiste les planches
non à combien de temps c'est petit plan
là là deux ans au moins combien temps il
faut attendre pour qu'un bon pied
palmiste rouge par exemple peut devenir
apte à consommer ici à 650 mètres
d'altitude il faut au moins six ans
qu'on maîtrise bien le sur le plan
technique dans les bassins philippe en
quatre ans et gagne avant un jeu des
shows de hockey voilà pour la cre est
ici c'est six ans au moins
concrètement de quoi a besoin pour
entretenir les pieds de palmiste donc
depuis justement au math aller à terre
jusqu'à ce que les arrive à maturité
pour couper pour finir dans le carré ou
en salade
alors vint nous comme nous les dans une
conduite biologique nous travaille
beaucoup avec fumier donc nous faut une
lettre au ton maître le plan de nos
maîtres fumier même si toute la planche
entière mirko fumier parce que ici avant
l'été pas en bio du coup mais essaye de
réactive la vie du sol pour que après la
pub besoin m l'engrais même si le
langres et les bio la pub usa met parce
que la manière moller a nourri le sol va
faire que le palmiste à tout ça qu'il
faut pendant toutes sa progression et
puis bien tous les ans il faut occuper m
beaucoup de matières organiques donc
feuilles servent en fait nous nous
laisse beaucoup poussé 1 et après nous
pas sa tondeuse dessus comme ça tout crs
au sol donc comme sa nounou travail et
au bout de deux ans trois ans une fois
que la fille n'y arrive au come ça l'à
beaucoup au moins besoin d'occuper parce
que nadal on met du coup c est du push
mois
qu'ils s'appellent sens
mais un paysan
[Musique]
dis moi il pas avec ton compagnon nico
enfin il m'a dit j'ai pas si c'est vrai
qu'il va couper appuie pas le mispo nou
té va essayer tous et nico il est là il
se cache voit pas trop quand même
donc bon je dis moi c'est celui-là
d'accord donc palmiste rouge
dis moi quelle partie les à consommer
c'est qu'en fait c'est au moment où il
ya le renflement là on voit plus trop
que on sait que le show commence à la
fin du renflement deux fois et alors
qu'ici on est sûr y'a rien là qu'il faut
commencer là ok ben écoute traque bon
couteau compagnie ghana
ça paye en otage
[Musique]
d'un paysan
valet
ça va
toute apparence
voilà la sphère du gardon alors il faut
il faut toujours bien précise de monde
parce que ça nous redire ou cissé
connaît pas quand on coupe ça compte ça
c'est pas un truc cougaing conserver
longtemps non 3 4 jours mais mange tout
de suite donc voilà l'idéal c'est que
annan a tout de suite ce truc pour faire
la salade de suite de type car il est au
feu comme ça c est connecté lac de dents
mal et ferez quoi hein c'est pas en a
fait autant de sacs si joie 1
[Rires]
[Musique]
sarr en gros il représente une année je
me suis pas aux cougars sa peau pourquoi
paul pour le grain pas besoin de faits
n'y a pas besoin d'aller rodez à droite
à gauche en fait tout est sur place donc
j'ai récupéré les grains et replanter a
vu les petits plombs tout à l'heure et
ensuite pour effet de gonfler palmistes
comme la cause est savamment j'ai des
bons gratin de pamiers
[Musique]
je
c'est le ami noir par l'omjs noir glossy
palme idéaux passé 10 pouces bien 1000
mètres d'altitude dans les bas au garat
pas fait pousser un et bien tant pis
pause ça qui habitent dans les bars et
sera un tube à morges palm ismaël est
non
[Musique]
dis moi combien de combien de mètres
carrés combien d'hectares de marais oui
nous faisons mètres carrés mais en
déclin fera plus facile on a deux
hectares exploités des exploités ou non
à de quoi dessus un parc valmy vétiver
non ça c'est pour les allées on a un
ananas gingembre nasa grumes pomelo
exciteront essentiellement l'a23 tizi
tangorre il traîne à l'ail à droite à
gauche
et puis un peu de son jeu un peu de
patates douces lamier sécher la vanille
aussi mais pas dans à boston tu m'avais
dit que tu avais une méthode en fait
dans la façon les positionner ces
mondiaux plantations oui mais en fait
mais travaillent dans les courbes des
niveaux c'est à dire que je travaille de
manière à ce que tous les points d'une
ligne de culture soit toujours à la même
altitude comme ça comme il marche dans
mon champ miné toujours à plat et c'est
un bon système anti érosifs quand
l'appui d'un paquet ben ça maintient le
sol
les plantations profite aussi de tout ce
qui descend vers lui et les jolies en
plus c'est beaucoup de plaisir
[Musique]
carole alors l'ami ouanaminthe à six
plans de palmiste exactement ça c'est
tout les semis fait et puis ben mis en
pot en attente de plantation ce plan là
les destiner terrain ou vend aussi des
petits plantes horticoles
ah bon bah ouais enfin un peu
particulier et puis après ben le reste
c'est pour implanter combien de temps à
massat mois pour élèves le semis et puis
là il doit faire six mois eut la met ici
aux canards et 10,1
[Musique]
je
devine sa c2 c'est cette partie blanche
à l'intérieur qu'on a mangé en salade
privilège rare privilège j'aimerais
savoir comment j'allais arriver là mais
pas la travail des agences immobilières
us avant d'accord pour mon papa et teva
pas mal du tout donc à 30 ans odile un
problème il faut enfin à faire et tu
t'es fait longtemps qu'on t'appelle mois
seulement bombe à caen ou centre le port
où il a grandi dans l'appartement quand
on dit on veut aller fait l'agriculture
fao pointent ce qu'elle est mais là le
métier là la fatigue à mama la prends
mon courage m'a dit non il faut mieux
cei puis ben nous lé là nous ne
travaille dur je veux mais les gars ya à
mon petit garçon 6 ans tous les joueurs
et là ils mettent seb a dit ça va il
prend le sa maman c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça grand isle de la nature me vois
pas ces nouvelles montres et nous voilà
des petits produits coup transforme
aussi la majorité de ma production enfin
la moitié on va dire pas sans
transformation je l'abordé confiture
achats siro même des produits comme tout
en leur dédiant dit pas de gingembre et
ça ait fait ça que les actifs est pas
aussi un ennemi amusement aussi à
trouver à imaginer quelle gomis à gagny
fait marié avec bendtner produits locaux
bravo merci nu comme ça me pourrit dur
on va dire votre compagnon simplement
parce qu'il n'aime pas trop la caméra
non à la prochaine tout le monde ne
retrouve et voilà l'émission se termine
on s'est arrêté au début du sentier du
piton babet saint joseph est juste là
vous avez la grotte des hirondelles
c'est joli c'est touristique c'est la
réunion je vous dis tout simplement
aurevoir à la prochaine et à chaque fois
vous oublier on n'est pas du tout sorti
de l'auberge
et ben non bah non
[Musique]